responsable mais pas coupable ce jeudi à
kigali emmanuel macron a entrepris de
recoller les morceaux d'une relation
diplomatique ébréché depuis plusieurs
décennies entre l'hexagone et le pays
aux mille collines
étape incontournable de ce rapprochement
le président français s'est exprimé
devant le mémorial de kigali où sont
inhumés les restes de quelque 250 mille
victimes des massacres de 1994 un
discours au cours duquel le locataire de
l'elysée a reconnu le rôle de la france
dans le génocide
comme nicolas sarkozy il y a dix ans le
chef de l'état n'a en revanche pas
formulé des excuses
les tueurs qui hantait les marées les
collines les églises n'avait pas le
visage de la france elle n'a pas été
complice le sang qui a coulé n'a pas
déshonoré ces armes ni les mains de ces
soldats qui ont eux aussi vu de leurs
yeux l'innommable panser des blessures
et étouffer leurs larmes
la france pas complices certains
rescapés du génocide sont d'un tout
autre avis même si cet aveu de
responsabilité constitue pour certains
rwandais une étape importante ce qui est
bon c'est clair a reconnu leur d'europe
france
diplomatiquement mais il l'a fait comme
je la fais sais pas comment va associer
des français qui allaient les barrières
qui travaillent avec les ex far qui les
aider à distinguer les tutsis et les
hutus
quand même ça c'est triste on établisse
a facilement fait clair ils ont
participé ils sont aidés c'était le
moment de dire pardon clémencin placé à
gauche at what
il n'y a pas eu le mans pardon mais
quand même il a fait un grand pas on
craint pas les mots d' emmanuel macron
semble tout de même avoir fait mouche
même en l'absence d' excuses
le président rwandais paul kagame a
salué le discours de son homologue
français c'était un discours puissant
avec une signification particulière pour
ce qui se passe maintenant non 1 deux
pointures will et qui résonnera bien au
delà du rwanda ces paroles avaient plus
de valeur que des excuses
il faut dire que la visite du président
français revêt d'autres enjeux que le
devoir de mémoire la teneur du discours
d' emmanuel macron la nomination d'un
nouvel ambassadeur de france au rwanda
un poste vacant depuis 2015 et
l'annoncent de 500 millions d'euros
d'investissements dans le pays devrait
contribuer à une normalisation des
rapports bilatéraux entre paris et
kigali